Now that you've got your
GitHub account set up,
it's time to make your
first public repository,
namely by putting your reflections
repository up on GitHub.
Like with many cloud hosted systems,
this will involve syncing between
the repository on your computer and
the version hosted on GitHub, which is
the version you will see on the website.
When interacting with GitHub,
the information you send and
receive is in the form of git commits so
changes must be staged and
committed before they can be sent.
You may notice that I didn't
draw a working directory or
staging area for the GitHub repository.
These exist for every repository,
but since the GitHub repository is
hosted on GitHub's servers,
they're not directly accessible.
So they aren't really relevant here.
Unlike with many services that sync with
cloud hosted versions of your files,
when using GitHub,
you will need to choose when and
how to get the two versions in sync.
You can think of this as being similar
to how git let's you manually decide when
to save a commit.
If GitHub automatically got updated with
your local version after every single
commit, you might end up making things
public before they're fully ready,
since new features often
require multiple commits.
So, since syncing doesn't
happen automatically, how do
we sync between the local copy of a
repository and the one hosted on GitHub?
In particular, how can you get the
current state of an existing repository
onto GitHub to begin with?
You might be tempted to answer GitClone.
That's how it got a copy of the
repository from GitHub to local back in
lesson one.
This would be a pretty
reasonable guess to make, but
it turns out that GitHub doesn't allow
directly cloning onto their servers.
So instead, first you'll need to
create an empty repository on GitHub.
Don't worry about actually
doing this right now.
The important part is to think of
an empty repository in a known location,
for the moment.
To allow for
syncing data between two repositories,
git has a concept of
a remote repository.
This let's you store the location of
a repository that you will want to
send and
receive new commits to and from.
Git users often refer to these remote
repositories simply as remotes.
You will see how to set up
a remote soon with Caroline.
But for now, I'll
represent the connection between
the two repositories with an arrow.
So what kind of interactions
can you have with a remote?
Well, you can push data and
you can pull data.
I mentioned earlier that what you send
and receive from remotes are commits.
But instead of selecting each individual
commit, the most common way to send and
receive data is by specifying a branch.
So in the case of this repository, and
most likely your reflection's repository
as well, all we need to do is push the
master branch and all the commits will
be sent since they're all reachable
by the commit at the tip of master.
So when you push master,
both of these commits will show up.
If either of these commits had already
been on the GitHub servers before we
ran the push command,
git wouldn't have bothered sending it.
You could imagine that if you had
a large repository with hundreds or
thousands of commits,
it would be very inefficient to send
every single commit every time.
Just to make sure this
concept makes sense,
let's look at a hypothetical situation.
If I had this commit history locally,
and this GitHub repost set up
as a remote, then pushed branch a,
which commits would need to be sent?
Note that here I'm representing both
repositories just by showing their
commit histories, since communication
between repositories only happens at
the level of commit history.
So it's not necessary to show
the working directory or
staging area for either of them here.